عشرات المهن ستختفي في السنوات المقبله
فبحسب العديد من الدراسات سيكون للتطور
التكنولوجي وتقنيه الذكاء الصناعي القدره
على استبدال اعداد كبيره من البشر بعض هذه
الدراسات مثل البحث الذي اصدره المعهد
السويدي لتقييم سوق العمل وسياسه التعليم
اشار الى ان ابرز المهن التي ستنقرض هي
مهن المحاسبين ومشغلي الالات في صناعه
الطباعه والنجاره والصناعات الكيميائيه
وغيرها ليس هدف حسب التطور التكنولوجيا
على اجاده بعض التخصصات الطبيه كتصوير
الاشعه وتحديد الكسور وتصنيفها وسيكون
قادرا في المستقبل على التوصيه بالعلاج
بحسب البحر وبناء على متطلبات سوق العمل
ستبرز الحاجه الى مهن دون مثل الامن
السيبراني والهندسه الطبيه الحيويه
والتسويق الالكتروني وهندسه الطاقه
البديله والمتجدده وصناعه الروبوتات في
العراق تشير الاحصائيات الى ان سوق العمل
في حاجه دائمه للاختصاصات الهندسيه كما ان
نشاط المجالات الاستثماريه وكثره المشاريع
المحليه زادت من الحاجه الى متخصصين في
مجال الاقتصاد والمال اما في الاردن فبلغت
نسبه اعداد المهندسين الاعلى في العالم
مقارنه بعدد السكان حيث ان هناك مهندسا
لكل اربعين مواطنا واظهرت تقريرا لنقابه
المهندسين الاردنيين حاله من الاشباع
التام والركود للاغلبيه العظمى من
التخصصات الهندسيه نظرا لازدياد اعداد
الطلبه الخريجين من هذه التخصصات
ابرز الاسباب التي ادت الى هذه المشكله ان
عددا كبيرا من الجامعات يستمر في فتح باب
التسجيل لتخصصات ليست بالضروره مطلوبه في
سوق العمل الحلول التي يطرحها المختصون
تتمثل في التركيز على توفير مقاعد لدراسه
تخصصات جديده الامر الذي يثير الحيره ربما
لدى الطلبه بشان ما اذا كان عليهم ملاحقه
شغفهم الذي يؤمنون انه سيحقق لهم فرصه
الابداع لكن ليس بالضروره فرصه العمل املا
الانفتاح نحو متغيرات العصر وتطوراته
المستمره في قطاع العمل كما انه يطرح
التساؤل عن حلول جذريه اذا انشائي اليات
استشاره وتنسيق بين الجامعات والطلبه
واثرهم وسوق العمل بشان ابرز التخصصات
التي تحتاج اليها السكان المحلي والعالمي
وتلبي طموحات الطلبه في ذات الوقت